[Music]
ephraim is with us in atlanta to start
off this hour hey ephraim what's up
hey dave uh first off you
what you've done for me and my wife and
our family's just been incredible we've
listened to you we've read your books
and uh
you've just been life-saving so thank
you for that well thank you actually you
did it i just told you what to do how
can i help
well
so i've been married for about 30 years
my incredible wife we
are living in the house that we've
raised our girls in so we're at the
point now where we're empty nesters and
of course like a lot of people have
a house that we just it's it's too big
for our needs right now so with the
housing market being what it is i threw
out the ideas of my wife to consider
selling it and her point was well if we
sell high we got to buy high well he's
right about i encountered that with with
going into living in an apartment in an
area that we love it's a multi-use
development with retail with restaurants
we're there probably three or four not
five days
a week and we love it there
so i propose that we get an apartment
there for a year to
enjoy living there and wait for the
housing market to come down and then be
ready when that time comes to build a
house or move into one or whatever
options we want to move forward with we
can but she's i think it's a lot of
sentimental that she doesn't want to
sell the house
but the rental is about 4 000 a month
which we could easily afford
and
we would make
probably close to half a million dollars
on the house net
okay
so she her
her ultimatum was well call dave ramsey
and see what he has to say
oh i'm the breaker yeah yes you will i
don't know if i can handle all this
responsibility a lot of pressure i got a
lot of pressure here
all right so let's uh let's change a
couple of um
a couple of the variables in the
conversation okay sure number one
i'll give you a 99
chance that the housing market is not
going down
okay
okay it has gone down
two times in the last 100 years
the 1930s and in 2008 it's only time
it's calmed down
okay and then it snapped right back
almost instantaneously in the 2008.
less than a year
those how even the areas like for
instance las vegas was the worst hit by
the bubble burst it was overbuilt it was
the fastest growing city in america and
it was in it basically the bubble
exploded there and we saw values come
down pretty substantially
and uh
it was
18 months and they were all back
and then it's gone nowhere but north
since then so i don't predict housing is
going to go down at all in this turn in
this round
uh my personal i do think it's gonna
slow down its rate of increase
but that does defeat your premise okay
as far as renting until then so is there
a property in the
area you're talking about buying a condo
for instance that you guys could just
buy and move into
well we could okay hypothetically there
is actual properties around the area
you're talking about where you're not a
renter
it's obviously very very difficult to
find it you have to be ready to to
almost make a cash offer because it's it
doesn't it's not in the market long okay
okay so uh if you could pull that off it
changes the discussion i'm not going to
tell you to go rent
you're going to lose that argument
so she wins okay
uh okay because i think you're going to
end up going in the hole with a rental
amount and values are going to increase
albeit not at the rate they're currently
increasing
so you're gonna you're gonna lose money
two different ways by going to be a
renter i'm not opposed to you moving to
that area and moving into a less
expensive property in selling your
property and buying high and selling
high which is her point uh but buying
high and later buying higher after
having rented it and
no i'm not doing that one
usually
and dave you and sharon just did
something similar so you all have lived
this um eve from
normally i see couples have this
conversation
and it's all about the house and the
math
yeah and this is a much bigger
conversation which is
this is we're we're sliding this into
phase three right we've had our time
together we've raised kids and we're
empty nesters and we built a
tremendous home together and a
tremendous life together
the next phase is what do we want this
next this next season to look like and
that it will include discussions about
home where we live and we want to go to
coffee shops and concerts we want to be
that couple we move out to the country
but that's a broader conversation that
as a part of that conversation will
involve grieving the the
leaving the house that you raised your
kids in it's got a lot of cool memories
yeah and it will what are your thoughts
about renting the house
renting it out
yes why do you want adventure rental
income
i'm just ready for change it's a it's a
5 000 square foot home
that just we
we live in a keeping room kitchen and
bedroom
yeah
okay
so i think that's the part you all need
to start talking about before we try to
do a real estate deal
i'm with john so the two of you need to
get aligned on what the future picture
is
of your life
and
what the future picture is okay it's a
smaller more efficient
use of the re of the square footage for
you
uh for her what is the future picture
and then what is the thing that we can
do that has all of the future pictures
in common
yeah okay
um and uh and you know you're gonna give
up some you know like if you have five
things i want your bottom two you might
not get in terms of forced forced
ranking and she has five things she
might not get her bottom two and that's
kind of what sharon and i just went
through honestly
um we did a little bit of a similar
discussion and we had this huge house
and um it was a good time to get out of
a huge house and so it's kind of stage
two empty nester for us
um and uh
it was a good opportunity to cash in and
but we did immediately or simultaneously
buy another uh property half the size
that we moved into
as a temporary measure until someday we
build and uh
but uh but we had a lot of different
goals with that that we both aligned on
the future
now the deal is i think if you if you'll
start if the two of you will sit down
like john said and start working on a
future picture let's paint the picture
together what five years from now looks
like all right now what are the what has
to be true for us to get to that picture
then you're going to start making moves
that are going to cause you to sell this
house move downtown into a smaller condo
as a temporary move than later on build
or something like that you're going to
develop a game plan to
end up at the same place
uh this could be a romantic fun
it's an exciting night the word we kept
using over and over is this is a pain in
the butt and it's an adventure there you
go we're signing up for an adventure
and uh you know moving is a pain
renovating a household moved in slightly
was a pain
with no workers available
moving is a pain did i mention moving is
a pain it's the worst it's kind of like
having a root canal and you know but
it's an adventure because we and those
are the steps we took to get to where we
wanted to be
five years from today